no one
is right it's really weird to sit there
and listen to all of that
those of you who know me or being in my
classes
i know that i do love to talk
but when i sat down and thinking about
what i was going to say today
i was truly at a loss i had no idea
where to start what to say
what words could i say that expressed
the gratitude
that i have for this place what kind of
speech
could adequately convey the impact
that these people and this community had
on me
nothing i could ever say would come
close but i have to try
so that's why i'm interested so
what do i want to tell you i watch truth
do i love to leave
green in your ears as i say goodbye
and i think what i want to do the most
key way to end
is to tell you a story this is a story
about paying things forward painful
one of the funniest things i experienced
while i was here as a teacher is that so
many of you
look to me as kind of like a version of
you but older and
there is a sense in which that is true
but i think the reality is that
i am one of the most unbruce-ish
kinds of people that this school has
ever produced so let's try and
justify that statement some of you
noticed in years 11 and 12
i studied no sciences uh this is
sorry the reason why i studied those
sciences is not because i disliked
science
but because i wanted so much to study
the nine units of humanities that i took
english
history drama i loved them to pieces
and i still do now i always kind of had
lingering in the back of my mind but
that was
a little bit weird for a jeju student
but i have very powerful reminder that
last year actually when year 12 i was
supervising
your first hsc chemistry task i was
walking up and down
the tables from this hall and i looked
around and i thought
this feels like the entire grade all
here
sitting the chemistry paper it must only
be the widows who don't study chemistry
oh that's me and so
i came to that realization but why do i
study such an unusual set of subjects it
wasn't just to be a sort of hsc to start
like physics is so mainstream
that was not the reason rather i studied
those subjects because
my teachers had encouraged me to pursue
those kinds of things because they saw
probably better than i did but they were
really good fit for my personality and
my character
and my interests it was the same when i
decided
i realized that i wanted to study
education it was weird
and unusual for a jj student but it
didn't matter
because james bruce was a place that
embraced the pursuit of excellence
whatever form it took and it still is
that kind of place
now when i was in university i went and
got my degree in education
but i never expected to actually come
back here
and teach so when i was offered a
temporary position here by mr wayne who
used to be the deputy principal
i literally jumped at the offer
now why am i so excited about working
here
it wasn't because this was a great place
to work even though
it is it wasn't because i lived
so close to the school even though i did
and it wasn't because the students were
so smart
even though you are i've used coming
back
as an opportunity it was an opportunity
to try and give something
back to the people in place that have
done so very much
to me i thought this will let me pay
back some of the enormous debts
that i owed to my teachers and the
community that made me into america and
today and you know what just saying
all of you right now sitting in this
room are in exactly the same boat
that i was getting even if you don't
realize it
you have wrapped up this enormous debt
to so many people
just by sitting there and being alive
okay let me try and explain
you owe tax payers for funding public
education
you owe previous generations of business
and their families
whose laundry contributions have paid
for and bought
many of the resources and buildings that
you use today
yes i am still somewhat frustrated that
i didn't get to use the gym
even though i came in six years twice
and you've also earned your parents
for raising you and most of you are like
me
in that you owe them extra because
they didn't just raise you they left
life as they knew it
to come to another country where they
had no money
no family no language all just so that
you could be
born here and receive all the benefits
of being an australian citizen
so we all owe this massive debt to so
many people
and here i was starting out at bruce
thinking yes
i'm going to pay back i'm going to work
hard and be fair
and swear and i did work hard
but the truth of the matter is i never
paid back
any of my debt what a cent
the reason why i never paid in the back
is because the longer i stayed here
the more i benefited from this amazing
place
i benefited from teaching alongside some
of the finest educators in the country
and learning the ropes from them i
benefited from being led by
people who saw it as their mission to
try and train and cultivate younger
teachers like me
and i benefited from being able to
constantly
interact with students like you
who showed me every day without fail
what a privilege it is
to be able to contribute just a little
bit to your journey
toward becoming intelligent creative
adults
you have the passion and the ability to
influence your world to look better
i benefited from all these people the
longer i speak here
the more i went into debt yeah it does
sound a bit depressing doesn't it but it
wasn't
there's a saying i'm sure then you
repair it which goes
you don't pay love back you pay it
forward
you don't pay long back you pay it
forward it took me a long time to
understand this
which is why i'm telling you this today
and i hope that you will understand
earlier than i did
we are all hugely embedded for those who
come for us
those who've led us those who care for
us
you will never ever in a million years
pay that debt back you can only
pay it forward you can only take all the
privileges
and resources and encouragement that
you've received in your lifetime
and pay it forward to the next
generation
you're going to pay it forward to those
people who look to you
as their seniors and their leaders
this is a scary thought their parents
now they'll never be able to repay you
but that's kind of the point
and it's kind of why i became a teacher
so that i could take the way that i was
taught to love
learning and sharing with others
so james ruiz thank you for everything
i thank you for being a place that will
always feel like home even if you do get
a gym
thank you for being people who are
relentless
in becoming the very best students and
citizens and human beings
that you can be and thank you for
teaching me
i thank you for teaching me about myself
this amazing world that we get to live
in and about the importance and the
privilege and the joy
it is to pay it forward